en dépit de toute l'horreur qui les
accablent de l' angoisse qui les
oppresse depuis plus de sept semaines
les parents des 43 disparus continuent à
affirmer qu'ils sont vivants
son fils josé antonio tissa palais
fidelio 20 ans voulait être instituteur
mais il aimait surtout cultiver le maïs
et légumes parce que l'école manque de
tout faute de subventions suffisantes de
l'état s'il est vivant alors où est il
c'est le gouvernement qui les retient
parce que le 26 septembre ce sont des
policiers qui les ont enlevés et livré
aux délinquants
le gouvernement doit savoir parce que la
police et le gouvernement c'est la même
chose à l'école normale rural raul et si
de l'eau burgos duty n'a pas il y a les
parents des disparus
les familles des trois étudiants tués
par la police et aussi les survivants
des fusillades dit voilà comme dérider
la crosse il nous rappelle comment ça
s'est passé dans la nuit du 26 au 27
septembre et se sont activés à casser la
routine acquéreurs c'était qu'il sortit
de routine dîner rien voter au on allait
récolter l'argent et surtout emprunter
des autobus pour aller à une
manifestation prévue le 2 octobre à
mexico les autobus comme ceux ci sont
ensuite rendus à leurs propriétaires
tout le monde n'aime pas c'est sûr mais
c'est une sorte de tradition
ils étaient une soixantaine et sont
venus d'haïti n'a pas dans deux autobus
et à la gare centrale digoit là ils ont
emprunté
de plus la police municipale les a
immédiatement pris en chasse à ce
carrefour 3 des autobus ont été piégés
il y a eu deux fusillades une de 21h à
22h l'autre au petit matin une nuit
infernale selon ce témoin qui vit juste
en face à la grosse
dans la deuxième fusillade à 2h30 du
matin il y avait un nombre incroyable de
rafale des tirs d'armes de gros calibre
de 400 à 500 balles ont été tirées à
quelques minutes de là se trouve le 27e
bataillon d'infanterie qui ce soir là
n'a pas bougé deux étudiants trouvé la
mort ici
un troisième a été gravement blessé le
troisième autobus a été littéralement
criblé de balles c'est une de mes pires
vision de la soirée cet autobus détruits
par les balles à l'arrière les pneus
crevés les vitres brisées et à
l'intérieur des normes taches de sang en
se penchant sur le côté on pouvait voir
que des camarades avaient été tués à
bout portant
parce qu'on voyait des morceaux de chair
selon eri la police a emporté une partie
des étudiants mort ou vif les autres ont
été capturés à la sortie de la ville
dans le 4ème autobus même scène sous le
pont qui vous souhaite la bienvenue à
aigoual à et en face du palais de
justice
l'autobus a été criblée talent
mary fait partie des quatorze étudiants
qui ont échappé par miracle aux tirs
nourris aux enlèvements des policiers
des narcotrafiquants trois ont été tués
par balles il y a eu trois autres
victimes sans lien avec les étudiants
bilan six morts et 25 blessés et surtout
43 disparus à toulouse il est accompagné
mince avance le procureur général
confirme que la police a livré les 43
étudiants narcotrafiquants ce qu'ils en
ont fait ensuite il présente les
témoignages de trois membres des héros
sonidos emprisonnés qui les ont amenés
ici à une vingtaine de km digues walla
dans un dépôt d'ordures ce qu'ils
étaient encore vivants les attraper
comme ça et on leur disait de se placer
là et on les exécutaient ont arrosé les
corps avec du diesel et de l'essence et
les autres ayant mis le feu ils auraient
été brûlés dans ce dépotoir pendant une
quinzaine d'heures jusqu'à rendre leurs
cendres pratiquement non identifiables
la plupart des experts affirment qu'il
est impossible de brûler décor
entièrement dans ces conditions surtout
qu'il a plu cette nuit là pas étonnant
que personne ne croit à la version
officielle nous avons engagé nos propres
experts parce que nous ne croyons pas le
gouvernement qui nous a déjà trompé une
fois en nous disant qu'il se trouvait
dans d'autres fosses communes
il ne nous auront pas une autre fois
d'autres fosses communes près 10 walla
ont permis de trouver les corps d'une
trentaine d'autres disparus dont une
famille qui avait été arrêté par la
police pour infraction au code de la
route est un missionnaire ougandais
enlevé en avril dernier
on l'appelle le couple impérial le maire
dit guallar hausse et louis sa balle cas
et son épouse maria del aux salles
respini aida qui voulaient succédé à son
mari à l'élection de 2015 ont été arrêté
un mois plus tard dans leur cachette de
mexico ils sont accusés d'avoir donné
l'ordre d'arrêter les étudiants qu'ils
soupçonnaient de vouloir perturber une
activité de madame on leur prête des
liens étroits avec le groupe
narcotrafiquants guerrero sonidos
affaires d'iguane a atteint pour les
mexicains un comble de l'horreur dans un
pays qui pourtant en a vu d'autres la
cruauté et la barbarie semble ne plus
avoir de limites ses impressions
parce que moi je pensais pas que
j'appris sept cas je me suis dit c'est
comme l'état islamique au mexique sont
les idéologies en plus d'où cette
révolte ces manifestations cette
indignation jamais vu mais cette fois
c'est la première fois vraiment qui on a
eu un cas dans lequel la police livre
non 43 personnes
on a retrouvé quoi et pour que les
aliments il ya un source on au moral
morales éthiques les gens qui disent ça
va plus
soit on réagit soit on
on va se
les pays de ses effets sous des airs de
petite ville paisible igual à vie sous
une sorte de terreur sourde que cet
autre témoin de la première fusillade
exprime ainsi paul est ce que c'est le
cercle ont dit qu'is goual est une vie
tranquille mais ni igual a ni aucune
autre ville du mexique n'est tranquille
on s'en rend compte des fois mais on a
peur c'est tu parles où tu dénonces on
vient de chercher longtemps porté tu
disparais qui va s'intéresser à eux
disparu il y as collusion entre
gouvernement et délinquants jusqu'en
haut de la pyramide sortent du
terrorisme ont terrorisé les autres
cartels terroriser les policiers les
l'armée et la population
pourquoi donc cette école normale
s'étire tel autant de malveillance de la
part des autorités du crime organisé
l'écho normal de yutz inapa est une
école pour les pauvres créé en 1928 pour
des indigènes qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'étudier ailleurs
les murs ici parle de marxisme léninisme
de che guevara et de justice sociale
l'école passe pour une pépinière de la
guérilla qui sévit encore dans les
montagnes de guerrero
depuis les années 60 on parle de
réglement de comptes entre les cartels
de la drogue est justement cette
guérilla
plus simplement soupçonnent le
gouvernement de vouloir se débarrasser
de toutes les écoles rurales turbulente
contestataires malcommode talent et ses
six étudiants logés dans cette chambre
il ne reste plus qu'un d autres ont
disparu
nos affaires sont encore en vrac sur
leurs paillasses tels qu'ils les ont
laissés neri restera marquée à jamais
par la sphère dit voilà il craint pour
sa vie
je me considère comme un des morts de
cette nuit là le crime organisé n'oublie
ne pardonne jamais ils savent qu'on l'a
redonné un coup ils nous connaissent
s'ils vont nous le faire payer un jour
quand tout se sera calmé
ils viendront nous chercher mais
entre-temps le mystère reste entier
où sont passés les quarante trois
étudiants d'ayodhya pas